after which even even knight x5 and  queen g5 might already be  bad news  in fact that is the winning blow knight  takes pawn is going to win the game for  aryan  it does it  oh it has it's going forward it's going  for it  and that's it  oh my god pawn takes knight queen check  and now it's completely hopeless the  king has to go to h8 but now  norwegian tv is getting very expensive  it is very exciting yeah because it's  not often  that the number two beats the world  champion  it's just game over like rook theaters  is there a cafe you can resign yeah and  magnus shaking his head  the seconds are ticking down and that's  it  arientari has beaten magnus carlsen in  the armageddon  oh incredible incredible stuff from ari  antari